Rockland County cops for their part are
deployed and ready to act we are told if
mayor Adams goes through on this and
tries to get more migrants to the quiet
suburban area that is not a sanctuary
County at that a point that has been
pounded again and again by Ed day the
Rockland County New York executive kind
enough to join us now executive very
good to see you so you were stunned by
this and you have no heads up or warning
right
there's none whatsoever we had to figure
it out ourselves and even when we
figured it out the the the mayor in the
mayor's office were not giving any
details we had to figure out through
investigation exactly where this is
going to be we figured out what hotel it
was we got we got information that told
us how many people were coming they
consistently refused to tell us when
they were coming so it left us no choice
we have no idea what's happening and I
resent the fact that somehow mayor Adams
thinks he has a hold on Humanity
um and being and treating people well
he's doing these folks no favors we
actually have a very Humane course of
action here we have we have great
um uh connections with our local not for
profits that we're at by press
conference today take treating people
right
um what the mayor is doing right now is
taking people trying to have a New York
City homeless shelters outside New York
City in direct violation of zoning laws
the areas that he has cannot even
legally put these these things up so
it's to a point now it's really it's
really absurd and you know this whole
issue about how many taken on is what we
got we have a situation where the mayor
of New York decided he wanted he wanted
a sanctuary County and he got it and now
he realized a bit of morning can chew
and he can't handle us he wants to he
wants to take these poor folks and dump
them wherever and 35 miles north of New
York City I don't think mayor Adams
knows what it looks like up there it's
just utterly ridiculous it really is
have any of them made their way to your
county
to the best well it's a very good point
Neil we have had people who have come to
our County we are caring for people up
here because people who who ended up in
the New York City area have family and
friends some in Rocklin they've been
here what that has turned into is a
thousand plus children in the East
Radford School District a 35 percent
increase in child foster care this is a
mitigated disaster we are at a breaking
point we are the we we were deputized by
the state to handle housing in Spring
Valley because they couldn't handle it
things are really bad to begin with
sending in 340 people now is about as
cruel as it can get because there's
nothing that's going to be here for
these these folks and it's it's that's
not Humane it's it's a political
reaction to a failure that's all this is
so you know the way to get to and from
New York City to to you and your
beautiful county is through uh Route 87
of course so do you have police do you
have security officials watching for
buses or the you know how would they be
identified how would you know
I Neo I'm a former police Commander I
know exactly what's how what has to be
done how it could be done I can tell you
and also the people of Rocklin that we
are making a very best ever to know
whatever movements are in real time and
react appropriately that's as much as
we're going to say but as you know from
past experiences of people being shipped
all over the country under different
systems I should stress it's oftentimes
in the middle of the night when no one's
looking
I will we're well aware of that and said
there have been some sleepless nights of
some people up here well let's just let
it go with that Neil we're not We're Not
Gonna We're not gonna get out out
thought out by by the marriage people
um so there was just to confirm
executive no warning that you had no
heads up from the mayor's office we
ourselves have reached out to Mayor Eric
Adams we've not heard back Hope Springs
Eternal maybe we will but there was no
hint of this to come
the only hint they got was a uh the town
supervisor at Orange title you had them
before she got a phone call from the
mayor and basically it's a courtesy call
basically and she confirmed that it's a
courtesy call it's a done deal that's
the bottom line the pointed question was
asked of the mayor was very simple are
these people vetted he didn't know
what kind of plan does that tell you you
don't know you have no idea who these
folks are that may be 340 beautiful
wonderful people I have no idea but you
don't know and you're taking them and
sending them to another another County
and and by the way how dare you you have
no control over this this County I can't
I can't come to New York City and bring
people there and say guess what I'm
gonna I'm Gonna Fill a hotel up in New
York City because I want to it's under
not it's under nonsense we are
independent of New York City and frankly
many New York City got a billion dollars
a billion dollars to fix this problem
and they're still complaining and
they're still reacting as opposed to
taking a plan and doing something
appropriate that does the right thing
for these people who are in a very bad
situation them he's making it worse not
better what's going to happen if they
come here they're going to stay here
they're not going to go back anywhere to
keep on growing and growing and our our
Lifeboat that we have that is data for
the protection of people in need like
any of the lifeboats it works only when
it's up until capacity once it goes over
capacity City it tips not only to the
folks who add you add it on go but the
people who were there I have
not-for-profits right now who are livid
over what's been going on here because
with all due respect to the mayor he
doesn't know what he's doing he has no
clue what's going on if you're in
Rockland he didn't ask his people didn't
ask I mean how do you implement a plan
and just say oh we're going to come up
we're going to come up one way yes when
are you going to come up oh we can't
tell you how do you residents how do
your residents feel about this
they are absolutely angry as and that's
reflected in the way I'm reacting right
now
um
you know if the man lived lived up here
in Orange town in Orangeburg near the
hotel right and this happened the upper
arms
it is incredible it's just out of the
blue uh a day I'd like to keep track of
this you can update us on that but this
dropped in your lap and it's like a
grenade uh we'll keep a close eye on Ed
day the Rockland County New York
executive again there was no warning for
this no update on what could happen
because of this and the responsibilities
that he and the county might have to
deal with right now whether they like it
over this we'll have more after this